when I told friends that I was going to
the West Bank I had so many well-meaning
people who cared about me and they said
now Rick you got to you got to think
about this they're they're going to try
to behead you I'm not and they were
sincere they were really afraid they
thought I'm going my life was in danger
and when I came back and said no they
were wonderful they were awesome I I've
got new friends everywhere I went I was
treated kindly they were like that can't
be true these are the these were the
Palestinians there yes the Palestinians
in the in the in Bethlehem in the West
Bank they treated me with such kindness
I didn't ask are you a Christian are you
a Muslim I didn't they just were people
they're just people I just accept people
for being people